all eagerness is a successful
businessman and one of the best known
faces in German football the allegations
have tarnished his public image mafia I
have to pay tax on everything I earn and
I think the same rule should apply to
everyone so the authority should follow
it up yeah I'm guys who don't have the
same opportunities as rich people to
hide money from the tax authorities
Omega Tom another Merkel's spokesman
said she felt let down by Honus whom she
knows personally feel dimension in
deutschland yet stare at many people in
Germany who are disappointed with Lily
harness and the Chancellor is one of
those people and of course it's all the
more disappointing because he's such a
respective public figure reports say
Ernest had set his hopes on a taxation
treaty with Switzerland the agreement
would have allowed Germans with
undeclared money in Swiss accounts to
pay a lump sum anonymously to avoid
prosecution the bill was blocked by the
opposition they now say the Honus case
shows they were right to stop the bill
story ended seeing this cone tax evasion
is not a trivial offense tax evasion is
fraud and it's a crime and that's why
we've opposed to tax treaty between
Germany and Switzerland for a long time
stoya up conga gimped but the government
disagrees it says the agreement would
have brought in billions of euros in tax
revenue once we thought that we would
have very much preferred if we'd been
able to force all those who are an
interest abroad to do their duty and pay
tax on it goblin destroy your flesh cut
off didn't her nurse says he turned
himself in in January if that was before
the authorities were on to him it will
mean he escapes jail